être un rasta ça veut dire se battre
toute sa vie bob marley considéré comme
la première star issue du tiers-monde
il symbolise à lui seul tout un courant
musical le reggae pour prendre la mesure
du succès du chanteur jamaïcain
direction le bourget à l'été 80 son
concert rassemble alors 50000
spectateurs record en france à l'époque
[Musique]
le pape du reggae voilà son surnom en
jamaïque bob marley partage sa musique
dans le monde entier des paroles
poétiques sur des rythme entraînant un
discours religieux social et politique
[Musique]
bob marley résume sa conception du
reggae en 1978 sur antenne 2 et st
dunstan stg et de reggae bob marley ce
sont 250 millions d'albums vendus dans
le monde
avant son succès d'autres artistes
avaient ouvert la voie du reggae dès la
fin des années 60 comme jimmy cliff ou
le groupe estime aaron hunt
mais bob marley reste l'ambassadeur
numéro un de cette musique typiquement
jamaïcaine qui inspirera des français
dont serge gainsbourg maintenant alors
que le reggae s'écoute en amérique en
europe en afrique sont rois c'est un le
11 mai 1981 bob marley décède des suites
d'un cancer à kingston en jamaïque
la foule lui rend hommage son groupe aux
ciseaux whalers au son du cal danse deux
de ses enfants
[Musique]